veamos si podemos aclarar un poco el
concepto del impuesto mínimo alternativo
el cual es uno de los conceptos que más
confusión causa con respecto a la
recaudación de impuestos al menos en
eeuu pero espero que este vídeo les
ayude a clarificar esto regresamos al
ejemplo del primer vídeo en donde
tenemos una persona que gana 100 mil
dólares y lo que voy a hacer es calcular
el impuesto mínimo alternativo para esta
persona y veremos qué sucede a partir de
ahí así que el impuesto mínimo
alternativo para alguien que gana 100
mil dólares ya he dibujado aquí esto
implica que si ustedes ganan menos de
300 mil dólares
los primeros 47 mil más o menos están
exentos cuando se calcula el impuesto
mínimo alternativo para esta persona que
gana 100 mil dólares lo que tenemos que
considerar es el balance que está por
encima de estos 47 mil 450 por lo que es
100 mil dólares menos 47 mil 450 va a
ser igual vamos a hacer esta operación
mentalmente va a ser más o menos esto de
aquí va a ser 52 mil
550 52 1550 de los 100.000 menos 47 1450
nos va a quedar estos 52 1550
lo que nos dice el impuesto mínimo
alternativo es que siempre que estemos
por encima de este límite este límite de
47 1450 se va a tener que pagar un 26%
de esa cantidad y si esta persona ganara
más de 175.000 tendría que pagar el 28%
pero este no es el caso estas cosas
pueden volverse arbitrariamente
complicadas si la persona ganara más de
300 mil tendría que pagar el 28%
incluyendo este otro límite que antes no
considerábamos pero como les comentaba
no vamos a complicarnos ahorita con todo
esto vamos a enfocarnos en este problema
esa persona tiene que pagar el 26% de
52.500 50 por lo que vamos a calcularlo
punto 26 por 52 1550 nos da como
resultado 13 mil 663 lo notamos aquí 13
mil 663
esto es igual a 52 1550 por punto 26 o
el 26%
este es el impuesto mínimo alternativo y
ustedes podrían decirme bueno no está
tan mal voy a pagar 13 mil 663 en lugar
de los 21 mil 720 que calculamos en el
primer vídeo pero que cree en la
respuesta es no la oficina de impuestos
va a haber ambos números y ahora que
ustedes paguen el que sea más grande en
este caso nuestros impuestos regulares
son mayores que los del impuesto mínimo
alternativo por lo que se tendrá que
pagar los impuestos regulares ahora esto
nos sirve en situaciones como en el caso
de las personas que ganan muchísimo
dinero en el que este impuesto va a ser
mayor pero en general este va a ser una
más grande si la persona tiene muchas
deducciones por ejemplo una persona que
gana 100 mil dólares pero puede deducir
una hipoteca y otro tipo de deducciones
porque el dinero que gane al final ante
la oficina de impuestos llega quizás a
cero
a lo mejor pudieron deducir todo y con
los impuestos regulares esto llega a
cero aquí recuerdo que no estoy
deduciendo impuestos y no estoy
reportando ganancias o entradas pero si
sigo quitando cosas de aquí puedo llegar
a tener una entrada de dinero muy
chiquita después de todo lo que quite
como por ejemplo 8.350 y en este caso
mis impuestos serían de 835 dólares pero
necesita ción se tendría que pagar los
13 mil 663 y este es el objetivo de este
impuesto mínimo alternativo porque
cuando las personas pueden tener todas
estas deducciones acabarían sin pagar
impuestos aun cuando sus entradas de
dinero sean muy altas en cambio de esta
otra manera se aseguran de que hagan
algún pago de impuestos